THIS.
AND WE THANK THEM.
>> Laura: IT’S ABOUT TIME.
I THINK WE HAVE PROFESSOR
LOTT AND ALLEN BACK WITH US.
ALLEN, LET’S GO TO YOU.
HAVE YOU SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
JOHN LOTT’S STUD Y.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY I
THOUGHT HE YOU WERE TALKING
OVER ME.
FORGIVE THE AUDIO.
THIS IS LIVE TV.
LET’S FORGET TO ABOUT THE
METHODOLOGY WITHOUT GETTING
TOO WONKY.
>> SURE.
>> Laura: HE PAINTS PICTURE
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS MORE
LIKE THERE TO COMMIT VIOLENT
CRIME.
MORE LIKEFULLY TO BE IN
PRISON.
MANSLAUGHTER, FIRST DEGREE,
SECOND DEGREE.
WHY DISPIEW DISPUTE.
>> EASY TO DISPUTE IT THE
METHODOLOGY DOESN’T WORK.
INCONSISTENT WITH THE STUDY
BEING PERFORMED AS WELL AS
DATA FROM THE AMERICAN
IMMIGRATION ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS THE IMMIGRATION
COUNCIL WHICH SHOWS THAT
IMMIGRANTS ACTUALLY DO LESS
CRIME.
>> Laura: THEY ARE ALL
PRO-IMMIGRATION, RIGHT?
>> I DON’T THINK THEY ARE
NECESSARILY PRO-IMMIGRATION
THEY ARE PRO-AMERICAN.
CATO INSTITUTE IS GOING
AFTER STAYING STATISTICAL
DATA INFORMATION.
>> Laura: CATO INSTITUTE?
YOU HAVE GOT TO BE KIDDING
ME.
KATO IS NOTORIOUSLY OPEN
BORDERS.
THEY DINE OUT ON CHINA TRADE
AND OPEN BORDERS.
GOOD ON TAXES TERRIBLE ON
THE OTHER TWO ISSUES.
>> WE ARE NOT TALKING JUST
OPEN BORDERS.
THERE IS NO WAY FOR JOHN TO
ACTUALLY HAVE THE DATA TO
SHOW WHO WAS UNDOCUMENTED
AND ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
HIS DEMOCRAT IS A SKEWED
INFORMATION OVER A LARGE
TIME PERIOD WHICH HAS DUMPED
AMERICAN NATURALIZED
CITIZENS AND AS WELL AS
PEOPLE HERE ON A GREEN CARD
IN THESE PROCEEDINGS MAKES
THE NUMBERS HYPER.
>> Laura: JOHN, RESPOND
QUICKLY TO THAT CRITICISM,
PLEASE.
>> I MEAN, THERE ARE A LOT
OF POINTS JUST BROUGHT UP.
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO SAY
EARLIER, THERE ARE A LOT OF
STUDIES THAT’S BEEN DONE.
THE PROBLEM IS THOSE STUDIES
COMPLETELY MIX TOGETHER
LEGAL AND ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
OR THEY DO SURVEYS.
WELL, IN THE CASE OF
ARIZONA, HAVE YOU
PRE-SENTENCING REPORTS THAT
ARE DONE THAT DETERMINES
WHETHER OR NOT SOMEBODY
IS -- WHAT THEIR CITIZENSHIP
STATUS IS THAT’S INCLUDED IN
THE DATA THAT’S HERE.
NOW, YOU KNOW, THERE MAY BE
SOME ISSUES THAT ONE COULD
SAY THAT THEY MAY HAVE MADE
SOME MISTAKES IN SOME
PLACES.
EVEN IF YOU BELIEVE THAT’S
THE CASE.
AND I DOUBT THAT, THE MOST
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
ABOUT 10% OF THE SAMPLE
THAT’S THERE.
AND THAT’S VERY SMALL.
THAT’S A MUCH SMALLER ERROR
THAN ANY OF THE DATA YOU
HAVE BEEN POINTING TO.
>> Laura: FASCINATING.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DEBATE
THIS, NO DOUBT.
I THINK WE NEED MORE
TRANSPARENCY, MORE
REPORTING, MORE TRUTH AND
THE LOCALITIES.